o no
[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau bienvenidos a todos a este
programa de radio francia internacional
y de france 24 la historia es esencial
para conocer y entender el presente hoy
hablamos de unos acontecimientos que
marcaron el siglo pasado y que aún
resuenan en este siglo 21 una aventura
de miles de hombres y también de mujeres
venidos de todo el planeta para luchar
del lado republicano en la guerra civil
española y es que se acaba de publicar
un libro que ya se ha vuelto
imprescindible las brigadas
internacionales fascismo libertad y la
guerra española y hoy hace escala en
parís su autor el historiador y
periodista británico giles tremlett jill
muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros en la distancia desde desde
madrid donde reside
bueno pues muchas gracias por la
invitación
y un saludo desde madrid bueno hay
muchos libros sobre las brigadas
internacionales pero tal vez una de las
peculiaridades de el suyo es que ha sido
el primero que ha tenido acceso
ilimitado al archivo de las brigadas en
moscú cuéntenos cómo ha sido ese trabajo
de investigación y por qué decide
escribir un libro sobre las brigadas
internacionales
bueno la verdad es que siempre he
querido escribir sobre las brigadas
internacionales se nos han muerto casi
todos ya pero yo llevo 20-25 años aquí
en madrid y he conocido a muchos
brigadistas y el tema de la guerra civil
española pues me apasiona
en cuanto a los archivos pues la verdad
es que he tenido mucha suerte porque se
me colgó en internet todo el archivo de
moscú que es el archivo de las brigadas
su propio archivo y por lo tanto pues ha
sido mucho más fácil poder pasear mejor
no por el medio millón de documentos que
haya hay ahí y bueno aparte de esto he
estado en en archivos desde polonia
hasta california pasando por londres y
ámsterdam y por supuesto por varios
sitios en español
usted escribe separar la verdad de la
ilusión y la propaganda es el mayor reto
que debe afrontar un investigador
antes de investigar qué idea tenía usted
de las brigadas internacionales y que
aprende con esta investigación
bueno yo creo que yo tenía esa imagen
que compartimos mucho es una una imagen
un poco romántica no de estas 35.000
hombres y mujeres que vienen a españa a
defender la democracia en un acto
totalmente voluntario no por entonces
pues costaba encontrar en grupos con que
compararlos la gente al final pues
optaba por las frustradas no
y luego tomando me con la verdad pues he
aprendido que no hay ningún ejército de
santos en este mundo y tampoco eran 35
mil santos ni mucho menos y luego que
toda la política interna de las brigadas
es muy compleja también tanto porque
porque la roca la república fue así
muchas batallas entre las izquierdas y
también porque son
hombres y mujeres de hoy día unos 85
países y eso es muy complicado el libro
comienza con el viaje en tren de una
periodista estadounidense muriel rue
kaiser que va a las olimpiadas populares
de barcelona organizadas como
contrapunto a las los juegos olímpicos
de hitler en berlín pero justo el día
que iban a empezar esas olimpiadas el 18
de julio franco del golpe de estado a
barcelona habían llegado muchos
extranjeros no sólo deportistas también
el periodistas y muchos se quedan para
luchar otros además se vuelven a sus
países pero luego vuelven a españa
porque lo hacen
bueno eso es muy interesante todo lo de
las olimpiadas que no que no se pudo
hacer porque es el mismo día estalló el
golpe de estado de los de los generales
reaccionarios digamos algunos
directamente fascistas españoles y ya
había digamos gente mucha gente de
izquierda es del mundo que se habían
congregado en barcelona para participar
o para ver esas olimpiadas y ellos
realmente fueron los primeros
voluntarios lo que es muy interesante
con las privadas es que muchas veces se
cree que son un invento de la komintern
y del internacional comunista y por lo
tanto dirigidos desde
3 de moscú pero lo que se ve con estos
primeros atletas y otros muchos miles
que llevan en los primeros meses de la
guerra es que hay
un deseo por parte de mucha gente de
estar en españa y esto luego con el
tiempo lo canaliza la a comentar pero el
inicio el impulso es más bien popular
escribe los voluntarios que se alistaron
en las brigadas internacionales formaron
una verdadera torre de babel no todos
eran comunistas pero tenían un
denominador común no eran todos
antifascistas muchos voluntarios
llegaron ignorando lo todo sobre españa
y algunos sobre la guerra porque algunos
eran veteranos de guerra pero la mayoría
no fueron mal entrenados mal armados
como logran organizarse y qué papel
jugaron en las batallas
bueno cuando ellos llegan en octubre de
noviembre del año 36 el ejército
republicano el que defiende la
democracia y la república en en españa
es un caos es un caos porque se ha ido
casi todo el ejército regular con el al
otro bando no el de los golpistas
entonces se está formando un ejército
pérez un ejército de izquierda esto que
lo organizan pues anarquistas comunistas
sindicatos y donde se cree que dar y
recibir órdenes incluso es es malo
porque no esté de nuestra izquierda es
mandar
y luego pues tienen pocos pocos o pocos
oficiales y básicamente no saben luchar
y los brigadistas llegan igual no saben
luchar muchos han sido pacifistas hasta
hacía poco y tienen que aprender sobre
la marcha les llegan las armas un día o
dos antes de llegar al frente así que
llegan con poca práctica pero llegan con
muchas ganas y uno de los de los
acontecimientos que se van repitiendo es
cuando llegan un grupo de brigadistas
nuevos pues son tan tan valientes o tan
estúpidos en el sentido de que la guerra
que van corriendo directamente hacia las
balas y mueren muchos pero ese mal en
pie también es lo que les vale
parece una fuerza eficaz y para aprender
rápido y por eso son cruciales en la
defensa de madrid una ciudad que no cae
hasta el final de la guerra hasta que
termine la guerra así que son muy
importantes al principio luego la verdad
es que con el tiempo menos pero son muy
muy por también hubo brigadistas
latinoamericanos quienes serán esos
brigadistas latinoamericanas que
latinoamericanos que perfil tenían pues
la verdad es que sabemos y sabemos que
hubo muchos brigadistas latinoamericanos
lo que pasa es que es mucho más
complicado
seguir sus pasos
en primer lugar porque no se daban tanto
a escribir sobre lo que habían hecho
esto hay miles de libros y libros de
recuerdos memorias escritos por sobre
todo por anglosajones pero al en danés y
franceses también luego les vendieron a
muchos en la brigada lincoln
que era de norteamericanos porque
llegaron muchos cubanos y otros
latinoamericanos que ya viviendo en eeuu
de hecho un club de trabajadores de
izquierdas
en el jalón en el club julio media
que proporciona pues más de 100
voluntarios por lo de más pues vamos
aprendiendo poco a poco quiénes eran y
que hacían lo que sí puedo decir es que
que hubo representantes de todos los
países de américa no una pregunta que
nos hacemos es si las potencias hubieran
intervenido en la guerra civil española
si reino unido francia o eeuu hubieran
ayudado al gobierno legítimo de la red
pública habría habido segunda guerra
mundial fue un preludio finalmente no
porque hitler probó todo su arsenal
aéreo en la guerra civil española
hubiera habido segunda guerra mundial o
habría empezado en el en el 36
pues eso es una pregunta muy interesante
que no que no se puede contestar porque
no porque no ocurrió así pero lo que sí
se puede decir es que para los
historiadores la guerra civil española
es digamos la primera batalla de la
segunda guerra mundial aquí entra a
hitler y sobre todo mussolini con sus
tropas con sus aviones y ayuda
directamente a franco mientras hay un
existe un acuerdo internacional de no
intervención que lo usa las democracias
liberales el reino unido francia y eeuu
como excusa para no participar sabiendo
perfectamente que hitler y mussolini
pues pasaba olímpicamente de eso no
estaban sentados en la mesa diciendo si
no no nosotros no estamos ahí
pero todo el mundo sabía que sí que
estaban y lo que ocurre en españa más
que nada es que es esa política de
intervención es lo que en valentona a
hitler ya mussolini porque se dan cuenta
de que los dos luego los que luego pasan
a ser los empleados en la segunda guerra
mundial pues no van a actuar
van a actuar y por lo tanto pueden hacer
lo que les dé la gana y cuando termina
la guerra civil española pues a los
cinco meses justos se invada por se
invade polonia y ahora empieza la
segunda guerra pues muchísimas gracias
ya no nos queda más tiempo si el
tremblay autor de este libro apasionante
las brigadas internacionales fascismo
libertad y la guerra civil española les
deseamos muchísimos éxitos bueno
muchísimas gracias a ustedes y espero
que los lectores disfruten disfruten con
él con él y muchísimas gracias y
muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir por internet en rf y
mundo.com y en france24 punto com hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]